so much to talk about first of all i
don't get to say this you are
look at this thing you got this
yesterday congratulations rookie
of the year
for you to give this trophy to me is
just incredible and i thank you
thank you very very much i'm gonna need
that back now you're gonna get it back
uh i i gotta just think about you you
slam dunk over
a car and uh the best part
is that you were fed the alley-oop by
your teammate through the sunroof
through the sunroof
that's which is my favorite that's my
favorite part of that whole thing is he
peeks out through the sunroof
and feeds you the ball which is not what
the sunroof was designed
for by the way i didn't know we we
you know we just came up with it and and
it worked out and um
i think people were scared when they saw
my teammate he's got this beard he just
poked his head up through the sunroof
and he was like oh
what's gonna happen yeah very scary uh
how do you top something like that
because you know next year people are
gonna say okay last year blake
jumped over a car and slammed dunk
what's he gonna do this year have you
been thinking about it
i haven't yet i need some ideas if you
have any fighter jet
fighter jet fighter jet fight car
on fire car on fire car on fire
yeah yeah teammate on fire teammate on
fire
car on fire alley from teammate on fire
you're dressed as chewbacca
it's done it's done well now everybody
knows of course make you
wookie of the year thank you
you got the assist and the basket thanks
a lot
seriously if you want ideas for next
year this is your team right here we're
going to help you out
i think we're good you went through
i'm going with that one so you're going
with that one all right you got a bit of
a hazing
uh from your teammates because you were
starting out with the team and you were
sidelined for a while
you were injured and so sort of a hazing
as a hazing
they made you they told you you had to
wear at all times adora the explorer
backpack and you did
you did and i you were very good about
it you wore it all over the place i wore
it a lot
um i think the best part was it was
waterproof
so you know
if we ran into rain i was covered yeah
do we have i think we have this
real picture
i i actually i saw i saw a little girl
in the mall
and i was like hey i have that backpack
and she just looked at me like
you you are an idiot
who is this creepy guy i have that
backpack
you wore everywhere and your teammates
would actually make you carry stuff for
them in the backpack wouldn't they
uh i carried mostly my stuff
he has some dignity yeah it wasn't just
embassy
it was my pretty pony not everybody else
um yeah i mean i carried whatever i had
to go get donuts for my teammates
which was awful so yeah
you